[Music]
on this tuesday night the canadian armed
forces finally names a woman
to be second in command what her
appointment
signals we're talking about a journey of
culture change royal reaction the queen
responds to that tell-all
interview one pandemic two different
financial outcomes why some canadians
are thriving
and others are barely surviving a year
of living and dying you see them today
tomorrow you come
they're gone reflections from frontline
workers
you wake up from your sleep crying
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with two long-standing
institutions shaken by accusations
in london the queen has now broken her
silence issuing a statement reacting to
that interview with harry and megan
we will get to that in just a moment but
first to ottawa and another shakeup in
the highest ranks of the canadian
military
lieutenant general francis allen has
been appointed vice chief of the defense
staff the first woman to get that job
she takes on the role at a time when the
armed forces is in crisis
the behavior of two top military leaders
is under investigation
former chief of the defense staff
general jonathan vance
and his successor admiral art mcdonald
and it's going to take much more than
one woman to fix the military's
deep-rooted problems
mike lacature has our top story tonight
what is obvious is that those measures
didn't go far enough and they haven't
moved fast enough
an admission from the prime minister
that his government has fallen short on
commitments to systemic changes in the
military
justin trudeau says there's a troubling
pattern of harassment and intimidation
or even assault
in canadian institutions not just in the
military
but also the rcmp and correctional
services canada
and trudeau is promising to do more
ensuring that we're putting in place
independent mechanisms to to put an end
to these these troubling allegations and
this behavior
once and for all it could start with the
appointment of the first female vice
chief of the defense staff
lieutenant general francis allen over
her 38-year military career she has held
a number of leadership roles most
recently
as canada's military representative at
the nato military council
but none of those jobs came with the
public profile and pressure
of this one i do think that in this
moment it's wonderful to have a woman
appointed in the role because
when we're talking about a journey of
culture change and having more women in
leadership positions
is is incredibly uh important to raise
their visibility
within the organization allen's
appointment comes as the globe and mail
reports the federal government is
preparing to set up an independent body
to investigate sexual misconduct racism
and discrimination
in the military trudeau wouldn't confirm
that report but it's believed the new
body will be outside of the military
chain of command
which opposition leader and military
veteran aaron o'toole says
is essential we had the last ombudsman
report to the minister of defense
and he sat on the allegation for three
years and he let down
the women wearing the uniform of their
country grilled about that in question
period the defense minister says he did
the right thing by directing the former
military ombudsman
to the privy council office no
politician
should ever be part uh to conduct any
type of investigation
immediate allegations reported to the
appropriate authorities lieutenant
general allen's promotion
comes as the military quietly demoted
the former vcds lieutenant general mike
rouleaux
to an advisory role he'd only served as
the military's second in command
for eight months global news can also
confirm what cbc first reported
that the commander in charge of human
resources in the canadian forces
vice admiral hayden edmondson was
himself
investigated over allegations of
inappropriate behavior
with female subordinates in the 1990s
the military says he was never charged
donna mike lokitori in ottawa
thanks the queen responded today to that
tell-all interview her grandson
and his wife did with oprah buckingham
palace issued a statement on behalf of
her majesty
it is brief and to the point the whole
family is saddened to learn the full
extent of how challenging the last few
years have been for harry and megan it
reads
the issues raised particularly that of
race
are concerning well some recollections
may vary they are taken very seriously
and will be addressed by the family
privately harry meghan and archie will
always be much-loved family members
critics are jumping on that statement
that it took too long that it
casts doubt on the couple's claims about
racism the queen has never done
interviews and for decades she has
quietly endured multiple family dramas
and tragedies
as crystal commansing reports the palace
is unlikely to be drawn into handling
this one in public so how many
grandchildren could go
i have three three as people around the
world talk
about his family prince charles focused
on his royal duties
lavishing praise on health care workers
and defense staff at a vaccination
center
i can only hope that eventually you'll
have a chance to see your families again
the royal family and its alleged
mistreatment of prince harry and megan
once again splashed across
newspapers online and discussed in the
streets
personally i think she's having a not
only having a pop at the royalty
she's i'm gonna pop up my country and i
don't like that
sadly i think i don't think it's going
to get better
since the interview i think people you
know you get trolls jumping on the
bandwagon
and i think it might get worse the queen
says the claims
made in the interview with oprah will be
dealt with privately
by the family mark burkowski is a
publicity strategist
although from pages uh formulating with
the hype that this is the greatest
crisis to hit the royal family
that's tosh uh diana was was was
a pretty uh pretty major but the
abdication
of edward and you know where the whole
question of monarchy was thrown into
into debate
king edward viii gave up the throne for
love
prince harry who has spoken about
feeling like he doesn't fit into the
royal family
appears to be following a similar path
even with
millions around the globe having watched
the interview
it's not clear if it will change any
viewpoints
crystal gomanson global news london
now two covet 19 and two trends that
were tracking the
spread of those highly contagious
variants and the rollout of vaccines
across canada more than 2300 variant
cases have now been confirmed
one of the hardest hit provinces is
ontario where about 30 percent of new
cases are now due
to variants canada's top doctor says the
next few weeks will be critical in
limiting the spread of the variants
while more canadians get vaccinated and
on that front there is progress
more than 69 000 doses of vaccine have
been administered today
canadians who are fully vaccinated are
still waiting for guidance on what they
will be allowed to do
bc's top doctor says she expects
something similar to the u.s
where new guidelines say fully
vaccinated people are free to gather
without masks
in small groups and right now we're not
at that point where we have enough of
the people who are at risk
immunized that we can have overall
guidance but i think that's a very good
example of what we can look forward to
as more people are protected
particularly more of our seniors and
elders in the coming months
to try to get more seniors vaccinated
faster quebec
is going against federal advice it has
decided to offer the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine to people across
all age groups including those over 65.
heather urix west explains the decision
and how it compares to other provinces
in quebec the race to protect its oldest
and most vulnerable residents from covet
19
is on the province says it will use all
vaccines available on this population
including the oxford astrazeneca vaccine
we have actually data from other
other countries too even even uk and
others
are using it after 65. last month the
national advisory committee on
immunization
recommended the astrazeneca vaccine not
be used on adults over at the age of 65.
quebec is the first province to ignore
those guidelines
basing their decision on emerging data
from other countries
that has not yet been peer reviewed the
information that we have about that
about the astrazeneca vaccine
is that it is very effective
at preventing deaths and
hospitalizations
across the country rollout plans for the
astrazeneca vaccine vary
significantly in order to get this
vaccine in manitoba
you need to be age 50 to 64 with a
medical condition
but in alberta you have to be under 65
and healthy
ontario just between the age of 60 and
64.
while bc has chosen to give the vaccine
to essential workers
who may be more likely to transmit the
virus we are planning
to use the initial shipment of the
astrazeneca vaccines
to address our ongoing clusters in
outbreaks that are leading to some of
these
rapidly increasing numbers in some
places some communities
when vaccine is in limited supply who
you vaccinate is really important
because we're trying to prevent
hospitalization and death
it's why icu physician dr michael warner
believes the astrazeneca vaccine
should be carefully triaged and given to
those who need it most
we should actually be taking the
vaccines to those people making sure
the most vulnerable people who have
health problems high exposure risk and
then age
get vaccinated especially as some
regions see colvin 19 numbers
start to rise heather urex west global
news
calgary there are questions being raised
about a plan
by some provinces to delay the time
between the first and second vaccine
doses by four months
about a dozen doctors scientists and
immunologists from ontario and quebec
sent a joint letter to canada's chief
public health officer and
provincial officials abigail beeman is
following this for us tonight abigail
what are their concerns
donna a draft of the letter obtained by
global news says quote partial
protection from a single dose
extends vulnerability to infection by 13
weeks
specifically highlighting concerns
around variants
there is actually no science or evidence
to support this decision
at some degree it is an experiment
because we don't have hard clinical data
vaccine manufacturers call for a three
or four week lag between doses depending
on which vaccine
canada is stretching that period longer
than other countries
to four months and the national advisory
committee on immunization which made the
recommendation
acknowledges no data exists for that
period of time yet
in response to the letter canada's top
doctor says
real world data constantly coming in
shows
efficacy is high after a two-month
stretch
and isn't expected to decline fast
increasing the flexibility
of the ability of the provinces
to deliver that first house which is
really safe and effective to as many
people as possible to
prevent deaths and hospitalizations is
paramount
the letter calls for at the very least
some mechanism to make sure the elderly
and people in high risk
groups can get their second dose on the
manufacturer's schedule
ontario for one has said that will be
the case for people in care homes
but at this point no one else donna
all right abigail beeman in ottawa thank
you the financial impact of covid19
could take years to fully understand
what we do know is that not every
canadian was dealt the same hand
mike derlay takes a look at the uneven
economic impact
of the last year you could excuse
canadians for being dizzy from the year
of covid
in and out of lockdown time and again
and while the health crisis unfolded
the economy took a beating yeah i think
one thing regardless of how you fared
during covid it threw a stick of
dynamite on everyone's
finances but economic downturns are as
unfair as they are devastating
for every canadian who needed government
assistance to make ends meet
another was socking away money they
would normally have spent on luxuries
like travel
financial expert kelly keane has been
speaking with both
that camp over there that has some extra
money they're actually reaching out to
me saying
they're kind of embarrassed to even talk
about it because they know so many
people are suffering
and the people that are suffering are
still dealing with that conversation
of you know tax times coming up they may
owe money
industry was no different after months
of losses statscan reports retail
numbers have rebounded
and real estate is breaking sales
records every month and restaurants
continue to struggle
along with anything related to tourism
and travel
add it all up and it's a confusing mess
for new graduates
there aren't as many jobs out there when
patty facey graduated with a master's
degree in information
she didn't expect anything to be handed
to her but she believed there would be
more and if you are somebody that just
was unlucky enough to graduate right now
you've kind of slipped through the
cracks when it comes to government
relief
she's not wrong 2020 grads didn't
qualify for the serb
nor did they get tax relief on tuition
like current students
instead they received the far more
frugal student benefit
and no help on student loan payments
people want to be
productive people just feel very
disillusioned with the fact that
we're you know as a generation so
saddled with debt that maybe we can't
have the same sort of economic
participation as our as our parents did
you know buying homes or investing or
saving for retirement
painting the canadian financial picture
has never been so confusing
microlight global news toronto
another blow to journalism today
buzzfeed which bought huffpost three
weeks ago is laying off 47 employees and
has closed half post canada
and half post quebec visitors to the
site today saw
this as of march 9th huffpost canada
will no longer be publishing content
23 journalists in canada are out of work
buzzfeed says it's part of a
restructuring plan for the whole company
huffpost canada had filed for union
certification in february
the union tweeted today huffpost canada
consistently punched above our weight
and did vital important journalism in
canada
it is a sad day for journalism
the case against the former police
officer accused of murdering george
floyd
coming up jury selection finally begins
this image is capturing lots of
attention a catholic nun
fell to her knees in front of soldiers
in myanmar and asked them to spare the
children and shoot her
instead two of the officers knelt with
her but behind her others
opened fire on protesters violent
crackdowns against demonstrators who
become
a daily occurrence in myanmar more than
60 people have died since the military
seized power in early february including
two people yesterday in the city where
that nun pleaded
for restraint in minneapolis a jury is
now being chosen for the trial of the
former police officer accused of killing
george floyd
the courthouse is heavily fortified
there with concrete barricades
fences and barbed wire and the minnesota
national guard is patrolling the grounds
what happens inside is being closely
watched
as jackson proskow reports even choosing
the jury is expected to take
weeks you have been summoned as
potential jurors
in a trial where everyone has seen the
key piece of evidence
potential jurors were pressed on how
they would decide the fate of former
minneapolis police officer derek shovin
who knelt on the neck of george floyd do
you think that might be a problem
absorbing everything and understanding
all the evidence
i understand but the only i know
what i see in the tv the trial will be
live streamed
jurors will remain anonymous and have
already faced a lengthy questionnaire to
weed out bias
no matter what verdict comes out of this
trial
we want it to be accepted by people on
both sides the death of floyd touched
off national protests and a reckoning
over race and policing in america
in minneapolis floyd's sister is in the
courtroom on behalf of the family
be a man and take action and take and be
responsible for
for what you did man up
you do the crime you do the time chauvin
is charged with second-degree murder and
second-degree manslaughter
prosecutors are trying to add a third
degree murder charge to give the jury
another pathway to convict
all of the jurors in the case have to
agree for there to be
a binding verdict in the case jury
selection could take up to three weeks
the trial could span months
the outcome likely to further divide the
u.s
jackson prosco global news
[Music]
golden comeback ahead the canadian
skiers seeing double
you're watching global national
[Music]
it has been an incredible week for
canadian skier mikhail kingsbury for the
second time in two days he has won gold
at the world freestyle skiing
championships
amazing stuff the reigning olympic
champion from quebec has now won
six world titles and 11 world medals and
even more impressive he only recently
returned to competition after fracturing
two vertebrae
during a training run in december
next reflections from the front lines
there is no way to adequately describe
the last year
none of us has lived through something
like it humans though are remarkably
resilient and yet this pandemic has
tested us
physically mentally and spiritually in
ways we still can't fully comprehend
tonight we have reflections from those
who confront life and death
every day karen lieberman has their
stories
outside downsview long-term care center
in north toronto
the sun is shining spring is near a
season of hope
but it wasn't long ago inside there was
very little
it was sad it's a place i don't want to
go back
plan is updated yes personal support
worker
velvon thomas calls it a dark time
when a severe covid 19 outbreak killed
63 residents
and one staff member you see them today
tomorrow you come
they're gone some you will see have a
little runny nose and a cough
and then you'll just see
the fish change completely change
thinking back triggers a flood of
emotions
you wake up from your sleep crying
you can't barely drive home because
you're crying when more than 100 staff
members were out sick
someone needed to care for the residents
it was like a war zone like honestly
we i don't know what
got us through beneath the shield behind
the mask
lies the trauma the horror of what these
front line health care workers witnessed
everybody went out in a plastic bag
and people think like oh you're used to
death no i'm not
down the street from downsview long-term
care center
at humber river hospital each patient
each loss is etched in the minds of
those who cared for them
we had a young woman with three kids who
before she was intubated
we called the family so she can say
goodbye to her kids
there's no words we cannot say anything
like we just
we just try to be there for them the
shoulder for them to cry on that's the
only thing we can do
in the icu death by kovid can be slow
painful if you have seen a picture of
somebody who is drowning in water
imagine it's lack of oxygen you're
looking for oxygen you see how
distressed that person is going to look
like
a harrowing depiction that will forever
haunt those on the front lines
and sometimes all they could do is be
there
you sing with them you sing for them i
remember one resident
i sing amazing grace how sweet thou art
forever we're gonna have this love and
respect for each other because
of how we just pulled through this
together survived it
yeah it was
a dark time karen lieberman global news
toronto
ryder times are ahead we hope that is
global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is buffalo pound provincial park
in southern saskatchewan
please email your canada to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
bye